every day you move breathe eat about 37
trillion cells are working hard inside
your body to keep you going these cells
are constantly replicating living and
dying as directed by your
deoxyribonucleic acid your DNA what if
one day you suddenly lost it would you
feel anything at all how long could you
stay alive this is what if and here's
what would happen if your DNA suddenly
disappeared for a start you'd lose
weight just a third of a pound or about
a hundred and fifty grams not the best
weight loss strategy DNA isn't just a
series of perfectly structured molecules
it's your body's library it stores your
genetic information and tells your cells
how to grow and function the moment your
DNA vanished from your body you likely
wouldn't notice a thing not until your
body started dying cell by cell and you
became a walking ghost how long do you
think you would last for think of
radiation poisoning
gamma radiation destroys your DNA but
you don't die from it immediately your
body still works or your immune system
slowly collapses the same thing would
happen to you if all your DNA
disappeared to keep you alive your body
cells constantly replicate themselves by
dividing nearly two trillion cells
divide every day some of them like your
bone marrow cells which are responsible
for producing blood divide more often
than others
they all need instruction from your DNA
to function properly without those
instructions they just stop working on
the bright side no one would be able to
steal your genetic information to
violate your privacy but after 24 hours
without a hundred billion new cells
producing blood your immune system would
collapse at this point even an ordinary
infection could kill you
after five days all of the cells lining
your stomach would die out to your body
would be unable to digest food you'd
suffer from gastrointestinal disease
resulting in nausea heartburn bloating
and constipation and say goodbye to your
hair since your hair follicle cells
would stop reproducing in a normal state
you lose about 40,000 dead skin cells
per hour
without being able to generate new cells
you could scratch your skin right off
within a week luckily for you you
wouldn't last long enough to experience
those Horrors rapid infection or
system-wide organ failure would kill you
within days possibly even hours you died
writhing in abdominal pain dizziness and
nausea the good thing is no one has ever
lost all their DNA yet
[Music]